let's go next to our caller from the I
this might be country code 62 or area
code 623 does either does either ring a
bell to the person who's holding I think
it's air is it air about six to three
yeah that's you
Phoenix okay gotcha what was your name
six to three Stevie from Phoenix Steve
from Phoenix okay go ahead Steve what's
going on I have a philosophy that I
believe in Medicare for all that I don't
think is I don't hear out there very
often in in our argument for Medicare
for all
okay and I work I work for a company
that is self-insured and I think that
Medicare for all would take the burden
off of business and my company there
works work spends fifty four cents on
every dollar in payroll and I think
saving that money would level the
playing field in our country and abroad
hold on let me let me make sure I don't
want you to get too far ahead without me
understanding your company spends fifty
four cents on the dollar in payroll do
you mean that for every dollar in
payroll they're spending fifty four
cents of that dollar on health care for
the employees or what do you mean by
that for benefits for benefits okay
so for every dollar that goes to
employees you're saying fifty four cents
are for benefits and forty six cents or
wages is that right
no it's an additional two I've got an
additional fifty for every dollar you
pay a dollar fifty four in total for
your employees got it okay and I just
you know I guess I don't hear anyone
arguing for Medicare for all just
because of a business philosophy and why
would we Burton businesses with the
picnic spent you know with benefits and
I just I just feel like you could level
the playing field on our country and
abroad and we could raise wages with
even lower prices in our business it's
very hard to compete with the Walmarts
of the world when they don't have that
burden and so everyone's not equal when
it comes to how low they can price their
goods you're absolutely right in fact I
just got a book from a publicist there's
a guy named Yui Reinhardt who recently
passed away who is an extraordinary
authority on health care spending and
one of the things that he points out
from research this isn't his opinion
it's his synthesis of the research is
that this doesn't always apply
dollar-for-dollar to every sized
business but that businesses are setting
wages in proportion to what they are
spending on benefits and healthcare so
if all of a sudden we came in and said
okay instead of having to spend nine
thousand per employee on health care you
now will pay into a Medicare for All
system and spend four thousand it's not
that that five thousand dollar
difference is all going to be given to
the employees but a portion of it is
going to be and wages are set in
relation to what employers expect to pay
in terms of benefits so your analysis is
completely correct the one area I sort
of disagree with you Steve is that there
are people talking about how this will
affect businesses Bernie Sanders for
example and others have said listen the
business is paying into private health
insurance in many cases the employee is
paying a part of that as well as co-pays
coinsurance prescriptions etc so yes
there is going to be an employer and
employee tax to fund Medicare for all or
whatever other single-payer system you
have but you're also no longer going to
have employer and employee contributing
to the premiums you're no longer going
to have co-pays etc so I think you're
right but I am hearing this pro-business
side being discussed you do hear it out
there that we're saying I do I do okay
from any of the major candidates I just
haven't heard that Bernie
Bernie's burning Bernie's reading
reading leading recent polls and he's
talking about it okay all right I would
think that Republicans would agree with
that being pro-business yeah they they
have they have talking points to refute
it which maybe I'll go over at some
point when when we have more time Steve
thank you really appreciate hearing from
you hope to hear from you again